hey guys this is Ethan from real-life
English and learn English with TV where
we help you to not just learn English
but to live it I'm back with a very
hilarious scene from one of the best TV
series of all times friends in this clip
you're going to see Joey has lied on his
curriculum saying that he's an
experienced dancer when in fact he's
terrible he has no skills so he has to
go in for a dance audition and you'll
see the funny situation that occurs when
he goes there if you want to take your
learning to the next level and really
learn all the expressions the vocabulary
the pronunciation the cultural notes the
jokes and so much more then I highly
recommend you get this free present it
is a PDF power lesson and in addition to
this we will also send you three scenes
just like this one which are exclusively
for our subscribers we will send those
right to your email so if you want to
get those you can sign up by clicking
the link at the top right of the screen
or in the description box below our
method is very simple you just have to
watch a scene with subtitles to get the
general context then you study and the
PDF power lesson that I showed you house
a lot with this last you watch again
without subtitles to test your
understanding alright are you ready to
see this hilarious episode and
understand 100% of it then let's jump in
to Joey's dance class oh yeah
[Music]
yes yeah guess who has an audition for a
Broadway musical I want to say you but
it seems like such an easy answer it is
me it's a musical version of A Tale of
Two Cities so I think I'm gonna sing New
York New York and uh-oh I left my heart
in San Francisco Joey I don't think you
get to pick the cities what mr. Dickens
gets to pick up I'll get you the cliff
notes the what the abridgement okay what
[Applause]
you got to pick a pocket or two boys
you've got to pick up
lovely just lovely really thanks this is
Joey
we definitely want to see you for the
callback on Saturday excellent I'll be
there okay and listen don't forget to
bring your jazz shoes for the dance
audition uh-huh
my ragin said that it wasn't a dancing
part
Oh Joey all the roles got a dance a
little but believe me with your dance
background it'll be a piece of cake
three years of modern dance with Twyla
Tharp five years with the American
Ballet Theatre
hey everybody lies on their resume okay
I wasn't one of the zoom kids either can
you like dance it off yeah I can dance
[Applause]
oh no no no no
so it looks stupid now there's no music
plan I have to get that but no no Joey
Joey Tribbiani listen Joey I got a
problem I just got a call from my dance
captain he's having a relationship
crisis and can't get out of Long Island
so does that mean the auditions are this
is Joey seeing as you've got the most
experience I want you to take these
dances and teach in the combination bus
Oh Joey come on it's easy you know it's
hand hand
head head up out of Rayanna for a big
turn here run - on something slide step
step
it says Stephanie step in Jenna's hands
have fun bye alright let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
what was that I know it's the best I
could get out of them
well people people people people let's
try it again and this time let's
everybody watch Joey show how it's done
[Music]
[Applause]
guess who has an audition for a Broadway
musical audition an interview or tests
where someone shows that he or she is
right for a part in a film play or show
by showing his or her skills as an actor
singer or dancer for example he went to
an audition with no hopes of getting the
part but he got it mr. Dickens gets to
pick up mr. Dickens mr. Dickens gets to
pick up I'll get you the cliff notes
I'll get to the cliffnotes cliffnotes a
series of summarized study notes of
longer literary works or complex topics
cliffnotes
is the company but these are also known
as abridgements
[Music]
pickpocket is to steal somebody's
valuables like money or a wallet or a
cell phone from somebody's pocket or bag
especially as they carry the valuable
objects around just lovely lovely means
beautiful or Pleasant or enjoyable for
example what a lovely day or that's a
lovely song we definitely want to see
you for the callback on Saturday the
callback is the act of calling someone
back especially after an interview
callback is a noun version of the verb
to call someone back Maya my agent said
that it wasn't a dancing part a dancing
part a role a part or a role is a
character and actress to play Joey is
auditioning for a singing and dancing
part in a play but believe me with your
dance background it'll be a piece of
cake your background is your collection
of experiences including educational
preparation your likes activities and
skills a piece of cake is a common
expression used to refer to something
that is very easy to do for example the
exam will be a piece of cake for Jack
hey everybody lies on their resume ok a
resume is a piece of paper where you put
information that's relevant for an
employer when you're trying to get a job
this is also known as a CV so does that
mean the auditions off the audition is
off if an event is off it means it's
been cancelled if it's put off it means
it has been postponed for example we're
gonna have to put off the meeting until
this Friday I want you to take I want
you to take I want you to take these
dances and teach in the combination then
teaching calm today
[Music]
this isn't teaching the combination
that's the best I could get out of this
it's the best I could get out of them
it's a musical version of A Tale of Two
Cities a tale of two cities is an 1859
novel by English author at Charles
Dickens the two cities referred to in
the title are London and Paris during
the time of the French Revolution so I
think I'm gonna sing New York New York
and uh-oh I left my heart in San
Francisco
[Music]
three years of modern dance with Twyla
Tharp five years with the American
Ballet Theatre Twyla Tharp an American
Ballet Theatre
Joey's lying on his resume by putting
very exclusive dance schools he never
attended this is what makes the director
thing that Joey is an experienced dancer
when he's absolutely not I wasn't one of
the zoom kids either the zoom kids is a
1970s American TV program for kids
yes yeah guess who has an audition for a
Broadway musical I want to say you but
it seems like such an easy answer it is
me it's a musical version of A Tale of
Two Cities so I think I'm gonna sing New
York New York and uh-oh I left my heart
in San Francisco Joey I don't think you
get to pick the cities what mr. Dickens
gets to pick up I'll get you the cliff
notes the what the abridgement okay what
[Applause]
you got to pick a pocket or two boys
you've got to pick up
lovely just lovely really Thanks listen
Joey we believe want to see you for the
callback on Saturday
excellent I'll be there okay and listen
don't forget to bring your jazz shoes
for the dance audition uh-huh my my
agent said that it wasn't a dancing part
Oh Joey all the roles got a dance a
little but believe me with your dance
background it'll be a piece of cake
three years of modern dance with Twyla
Tharp five years with the American
Ballet Theatre hey everybody lies on
their resume okay I wasn't one of the
zoom kids either can you like dance it
off yeah I can dance
[Applause]
oh no no no no no it looks stupid now
there's no music playing I have to get
that but no no
[Music]
Joey Joey Tribbiani listen Joey I got a
problem I just got a call from my dance
captain he's having a relationship
crisis and can't get out of Long Island
so does that mean the auditions are this
is Joey seeing is you've got the most
experience I want you to take these
dances and teach in the combination bus
Oh Joey come on it's easy you know it's
Han Han head head up out of gray for the
for a big turn here run to jump slide
it says Stephanie step in Jenna's hands
have fun bye alright let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
what was that I know it's the best I
could get out of them
well people people people people let's
try it again and this time let's
everybody watch Joey show them how it's
done did you love this lesson then
remember to click here to join our free
three-part mini course
teaching you English with your favorite
TV series